no yeah i could just come to my yard
lips me tug me off and leave nah nah if
getting your knees will go in your back
get on your knees or get in your back
alright ladies and gents here we are
again
welcome welcome welcome
so i can't open this monster
my wrist was about to snap um those
jokes
so guys you know the drill if you want
that raw
uncut effing and blinding head on over
to uh
patreon we've got the juicy juice lots
of squeeze
um link in the description if
you like us on youtube like us on
youtube
yeah rest of thing from these
livestreams yeah these things don't
happen themselves
um help a man out with the algorithm and
that um
bro if you'd like to listen order terry
then uh leave a nice review for us
please that will be lovely
a nice little if you listen to apple
podcast especially leave a nice review
helps us in the chats ratings at five
stars
offs nothing less
so yeah uh thank you and um yeah gee you
got a fun fact for us today
always broski um so
it's kind of like a question as well as
a fact yeah
um could you possibly guess what you
think the most
viewed youtube video is
ever ever the most
viewed youtube video ever or played most
players or whatever
chocolate rain you don't know about
chocolate rain
like chocolate rain you don't know about
chocolate right i might know if you give
me context there's a little
geeky guy yeah um
who made a song years ago yeah this is
when youtube was
new and he called it chocolate rain and
it's just him singing in a real deep
voice he's the
like skinniest geeky kind of guy let me
try and find it real quick
chocolate rain bro
chocolate rain you know someone please
someone comment if you know about
chocolate rain i've
i might have heard of it but sadisky's
oh yeah he looks about seven years old
but he's actually like 46.
[Music]
seven years old
e come on
and again
my guy that's got 128 million views
okay i've seen it about 127 million
times
wait chocolate rain was the [ __ ] when i
was like 11 years old
that is hilarious but no it's not that
unfortunately
um could you have could you waver
another guess
most viewed youtube video of all time
i'm trying to think of like a viral
it's not ouch charlie is it no it's not
actually
what is it it's baby shark
that that does not surprise me bro
that does not surprise me it was
annoying i hate baby showers it was
annoying
fair play though but no guess how many
views you think has got oh how do you
move
500 million no more
a billion five billion
so i'll just tell you 9.64 billion
no too much 7 billion
it's got 7.04 billion views
on youtube so that basically means every
single
person on planet earth i've seen it
every single day literally means every
single person on planet earth
has seen baby shark that's ridiculous
that is ridiculous they must have bought
in
cake on that
adverts alone stupid cake
even if they're even if they're working
at the worst cpm of all times
they're probably let's just say they're
bringing in a dollar per thousand views
just say worst case scenario they're
bringing in one dollar per thousand
seven billion what even is that i can't
even i don't know
from one video i don't know it's like
700 million i don't know it's a lot of
money
there's a lot of money there's too much
money that's a ridiculous problem one
thing i think here's 700 million
jesus i think it is we'll just be
seven billion divided by a thousand
right yeah which would be 700 million
i think i don't know i don't know oh no
no it would be like seven million if you
could save a million seven million it'd
be like seven million yeah
not 700 million yeah yeah seven million
times a thousand would be seven billion
anyway seven meals off is a lot of money
for one video yeah it's a lot of [ __ ]
money
that's a lot of [ __ ] money seven mil
for one vid
or that's if they're making one dollar
per ten thousand they're making more
than that so it's probably about
yeah it's probably about 700 million
no but yeah wild but you know the first
video
that reached a one billion views can you
have a guess
the first ever video that reached one
billion a billion
and we we know this song it's not it's a
song yeah yeah it's a song this one's
actual song is it by drake
no that surprises me also
first the first ever video that reached
a billion views first ever
video to reach a billion views was a
viral song yeah very [ __ ] viral
a [ __ ] throat cool
swear more though right sorry
do you monetize as quick
wow what we no know this song
i think everyone knows this song i think
everyone
that listens or watches this genre is it
knows this song
i don't even know i actually don't know
what the genre is
cool man um i would say it's like a
dance technoe
how many years ago were talking probably
eight
eight years ago eight nine
is it um gangnam style yes it is
yeah gangnam style
the first time i heard that yeah gasps
first time i heard that
it was um a moment i was we were in uni
yeah this is yeah it came out a long
time ago we were in uni
second year third year yeah and um i was
at a girl's house
and she said to me that ah let me play
you this song
this korean like k-pop song and i
remember thinking
shut up and i insisted in my head at the
time that i was like i'm not
i'm refused to like this yeah yeah yeah
i don't care what you play me i'm not
gonna like it
and bro like 35 seconds in i was just
like
i can't help but like it i hate the fact
that i like it but i can't
help myself it's just it was just a
great error for him
it was a great error for him and
remember you have a song uh gentlemen
i'm a [ __ ] gentleman that came
out straight after not straight after
but it was the second
he made cake
speaking of koreans did you know
you know the band um bts yes biggest
band on planet earth yes
they're um did you know like in korea
for like
k-pop and stuff they take it serious
cause seriously what sense
in the fact that they like they
orchestrate this thing
so they just take a group of people
so say bts the bts were orchestrated
yeah they're just a group of
singer stroke dancers that some manager
kind of like one direction put them all
together said right
here's the thing all you men are cool
singers
you're going to make a group called bts
you're all going to get
plastic surgery on your faces to make
you look hella female
these are the songs you're going to
write oh or sing no none of you men are
writing your own songs
you're just they're basically just there
to sing and dance
who's orchestrating this their manager
oh sure
so they have deals where they like sign
over because then no one at this point
so it's basically like give me your soul
forever and i'll make you the biggest
thing on planet earth yeah and you'll be
rich but i'll be richer
kind of thing so apparently their
contract i don't know how long it's for
probably like 100 years and their
managers are billionaire
and they make seven mil each a year
that's their contract seven mil each a
year
and he takes everything else and they're
the biggest panda planet earth
but when you're nothing if a man says
i'll give you seven mil a year
i'm taking it of course but don't you
think that's
weird how things change though yeah in
that right now someone offered me seven
million a year yeah
there shouldn't ever be a point in my
life where i'm like i deserve more than
seven yeah yeah yeah
no one on planet earth deserves more
than seven million a year unless you're
jeff bezos unless you've
started something that has grown so
exponentially that is bigger than any
one person yeah yeah yeah
if you're if you're getting paid for
services done by you
yeah no one on planet earth ever
deserves more than seven mil
that's that's too much money it is until
you know how much you could be making
that's the annoying part and then you're
like wow i'm vexed now yeah wow
off the stuff i'm doing you're making
this much mad rummy i'm in my pieces
cancel the contract run me everything
that's when you're fixed
i'd rather not find out how much he's
making yeah yeah same with like taxes
when people get vexed about taxes
i can't tell you the last time i checked
my paycheck i don't look at my paycheck
really
because i don't want that i don't want
to know what i could have made
before elizabeth took it i thought you
meant on like when you get the yearly
tax thing
i didn't think you meant month by month
oh my mom i've never i do not i haven't
looked it's been two years plus i've
never checked it i check it every month
i don't i don't want to do it to myself
yeah i know how much i come out with
every month yeah yeah yeah so if there
was a big
like discrepancy i'd have to query it
yeah yeah but like and as long as it's
around about the figure
i don't want to know how much student
finance takes off me i don't want to
know how much the government takes off
me
national insurance i don't even know
what that is
i don't even know what that is and they
take loads
so couple i don't want to know
that's crazy i haven't checked in years
that's because i'm i'm livid about it
and that's why like i don't know how
amanda um well when we quit we have to
do the self-employed thing yeah
i'm gonna be livid i'm going to be livid
because then i'm gonna have to do the
tax returns every year i'll say me
someone's gonna do it
and whoever does it i'm gonna end up
knowing how much we could have made
if we weren't paying x amount percentage
in tax to lizzie
and they would have to have that money
to literally pay on the day
because when you do a yearly tax thing
you have to it's not going to come out
of nowhere
no one's going to take it from you you
have to physically give it to them
that's what wizzy snipes is pen was in
pen
that's because these men in america
everyone in america does that well i
know that's i couldn't live like that
i'd be in jail right now
if i'm a dustbin man or a lorry driver
and i'm giving you grands at the end of
the year when i've got
not money got money for milk and i'm
giving you cake
out my account how have any of them got
the willpower to keep the money to keep
the money and save it there must be a
system that i'm not aware of yeah when
it comes to tax returns
there has to be because i'm going to
jail i know that if i'm not here because
i'm not paying tax
i couldn't fathom it for a whole year if
i can go a month without i'll be happy
bro if i can go a month without paying
tax i'll be happy
same here bro that's why and i think
this is what i don't think i've ever had
i think
i've had one 20 pound tax return a tax
rebate sorry
20 20 pound in my whole life one 20
pound tax rebate
everyone who's ever been close to me has
had over a grand at some point when
someone i know had a grand and a half
in the last one i think in april or may
or something grand and a half i was
livid
i checked my post box every day for a
week
because you're certain you should be
making more than this
nothing especially i have to be making
more than this
nothing bro there's one guy i was
working with um when i was working as a
pt
um tyrone his name was he came out one
time with like three four
grand is it i really pay
no was he hourly paid no no we were on
salary oh wow so this is he was getting
hourly
pay pt money but that was cash in hand
his actual so we had to do 24 hours a
week working for the company
just just doing either three sessions
for people or group classes and all that
[ __ ] yeah
so they would pay us for that 24 hours a
week
so from making 24 hours a week he was
coming out with what 800 a month
um and from that 800 a month
still got owed back 3-4 grand at the end
of the year he must have been living on
scraps
he must have not needed the job jesus
because he didn't even notice
jesus then it came back and i was like
at the time i'd never seen that amount
of money
i'd never had that amount of money in my
account i was livid
it's the yeah tax is the best savings
tool ever yeah
yeah you just give it back and be like
cool this is what you actually say this
is your money you know this is your
money we just took it without your
choice and now you're gas that you get
back
bro it's a fickle world i've never had
one they've they've sussed the system
bob
20 pound but i've had twice
i get the hmrc letter through the post
i've had this twice to me now
where i look it and i'm thinking gang
tax rebate run me my money
i'll open it they say i owe them money
they said they can't get anything wrong
i owe them money so now they're going to
take
more that's happened to me twice how is
that how is that possible how have you
calculated wrong when you work for a
company that calculate it for you
surely it's automated right calculate
your things fam
why am i now being scrutinized for your
mishap
it's been a year family you know with me
a lot we should have figured this out
leave me alone what do you mean you're
taking an extra bill a month oh god no
for the next 12.
god and you're chatting like you're
doing me a favor
angry fam that's happened to me twice
nah that's never happened to me
vex um i think it's no it's only
happened to me
when i've changed jobs in like the first
couple months this is back when i was on
hourly not salary mm-hmm first couple
months because i think they put you on
an emergency card if you get your
wrong tax code yeah yeah i could be i
think it's kind of like br this is in
the uk anyway i don't buy anywhere else
um you give you like br something
something something that's like the
emergency code and you get overly taxed
so you get that back after that's when
you get the rebate yeah yeah but apart
from that
that's what you just said yeah if i'm
like people love to screw me when it
comes to p
like if i get a big injection of money
at any one point
i know something bad is about to happen
in my life because every time i've ever
been comfortable comfortable with money
in my life something bad has happened
that's gonna take the money from me
every single time my life
and we already know i have the worst
luck in life but this is true
i remember one time i had an extra like
extra it was up to like a few months to
save and i was doing well savings i had
an extra grand in my account
nice i remember those days and i was
like okay i'm i'm set now yeah cause i
don't need to touch it i'll maybe dip in
50 pound here 55 there
it's not like i was ever saving for
anything so it's just a healthy great
it's just like my account is in good
stead right now yeah and there's no
reason
on planet earth why i would never need
to spend it i'm just set now
yeah fam next week i took my car into a
garage for mot
it was like seven eight i think what are
you telling me fam i think i remember
you telling me
i've never been so upset the whole thing
just gone gone
take it have it i spent it i didn't even
think about it because i was like
let me just get rid of this money now
before i it actually gets into my chest
and i start getting angry about it
another time was when i was getting paid
weekly as a pt
and i had about five bills i think i had
like five six bills
that when you're getting big weekly you
just got money you've got money coming
in
remember when i used to [ __ ] get paid
weekly bro best
best thing ever bro as a bartender oh
i was throwing money away bro that's
frame anyway sick
it's sick music and then um my dad took
us on a trip to grenada
and i was like you know what yeah i'm
just gonna spunk the whole 500 in
grenada because i just don't need it
it's just sitting there
i'm getting paid weekly i'm saving so
much money it's just easy for them
let me go on holiday and live live so i
spunk the whole five bills in grenada
mostly on souvenirs because it was
all-inclusive so i had nothing to spend
on i made excuses to spend
spunk it spunks it came back with a
smile on my face came back to work
the day after had an email from a boss
like cool
just so you know this was a shady
company shady shady company we didn't
even have a pension scheme
that's illegal by the way i remember i
told my brother he loves pensions
i don't know my brother he loves hitches
and he was like oh when i got that job
he was like
oh cool what's the pension scheme like
that who asked her he's younger than me
he's two years younger than me
man said what pension scheme are you on
and i was like
i don't think we have a pension he was
like bro that's illegal
don't work there and i was like it's too
late i'm there i'm there they pay me
weekly it's fine
who needs a pension the thing is as well
this i better be rich in my life
yeah because i don't care about pensions
at all yeah and it needs to i can't be
the guy that's like
i wish i can't take care of about
pensions when i was younger because i
just don't yeah because i've been
always been that cocky dude that because
my brother loves pension so much
every time he brings pensions up to me
i'm like yo my bank account will be my
pension big man i'm gonna be caked and i
say it to annoy him yeah
but deep down i'm like please let that
be the case please let me because if i'm
a 65 year old man by that time it's
probably gonna be 75
yeah and i'm gonna be like i'm broke i'm
broke
because the vodka didn't work out i made
some bad investment choices
and now i'm stuck and he's gonna be
living lavish
oh he's already calculated diversity
with a
every time he gets a pay rise or
something like that he's already
calculated because he wants to have a
million quid
in the bank pension wise oh wow when he
retires i think he's sussed at that
if he keeps going where he's at he's
going to be like 45 50
and he'll have a million quid and he's
just going to quit oh wow that's what he
said
45 50 is quitting because he's going to
have a million quid and he can he's
already
he's got a spreadsheet for the whole
thing my body my brother stays busy
that's great but anyway back to the
point spunk the five bills came back
got a new uh email from my boss just
read it just tanned
living lavish just turned just tan just
gas listening teeth looking white
and then uh it's a cool just let you
know and we've switched it from weekly
to monthly
and the weekly thing was never supposed
to be like a long-term situation but it
was like
the whole time i'd worked there but
apparently unbeknownst to me
before i started working there there was
a situation where they were getting paid
monthly
some a couple of the trainers because
it's a pt company a couple of the
trainers
made some bad decisions with their p and
they just weren't doing well
monthly wise and i think it's because it
was something to do with
they were self-employed and had to go
for an accountant and they weren't sure
of this and that and there was like a
big upfront payment and then they had to
pay taxes in lieu
like a couple of them started in like
april time and then they had to pay
taxes in lube and all this
like it was a whole financial mess and
it just ended up somewhat like their
first couple months they were coming out
with like four or five hundred pound
in the and then like otherwise they're
kind of uploads and it was just a whole
mess that they said
basically oh let's just change it yeah
we're gonna change it to weekly for the
foreseeable future and
once everyone's set we're gonna change
it back to monthly yeah yeah
i didn't know any of this i've been
there for like a year at this point
happy galore tuesday comes my money
ain't run
check my email i said we switched it to
monthly
and by the monthly say we get paid on
the 17th
this was like the 19th at this point so
i'm gonna have to wait no it was
no no no no no what was it it was i
cause i know it was over a month so
let's say no it must have been a case of
we get paid on like the 30th it was like
the 17th at this point
but they're not paying me this 30th
because they just paid me a week
last week i've spunk the whole five
bills so i've got my
i think i used to come out with like 370
a week at the time so i've got my
pounds on the like 18th now to last me
until the 30th of next month
let me sink that in again i've got 370
pounds
to last me from the 18th to the 30th of
next month
and i've just spunked my life savings in
grenada
my life savings
bro do you know the funny thing about
that story i think you told me this you
definitely i definitely have
because i probably asked you for money
three times yeah probably did
um but because i remember
[Music]
it happened after i switched from our
hourly to salary i remember it was
because obviously i was not obviously i
was a bartender before i was a manager
in hospitality and i remember the
i think i remember the week i did the
switch um
i think i had gotten paid maybe like i
got paid in week one and obviously i had
to wait till week four to get paid again
i didn't cut my hair i didn't cut my
hair for three weeks
i didn't cut my hair three weeks firm
speaking of haircuts i need a haircut
just look down easter end i need a
haircut asap
it's getting it's getting desperate guys
i need a trim
i do rex on i need to try um but yeah
i splunk different fam and then i'm sure
probably fam i would have reached out to
you
and said help i would have reached out
to you and said help
please i can't i'm not going to make it
my overdrive got murked
oh i bet i bet
i finally bro jesus
that i think that was the beginning of
the end of like
my credit situation like it's just it
just got marked from then and it just
never really couldn't
yeah it was long
every day you had every time you had a
good month the next month was thinking
back in the day bro
it was long man monthly pays long a
month
i remember um this is louis's fault he's
a waste
when i said ages ago that i wanted to be
a youtuber
years ago now what three years ago now
um
he said to me one time we were just
discussing it he loves youtube so much
and we were just discussing it and um he
says to me
oh and i think he just said it oh i
think youtube paid weekly as well
god knows where he got this information
from but he just said it and i was like
you've just certified it for me now i
know i'm going to be youtube because i
need weekly pay
i need weekly bet and it's never going
to happen anymore i'm never going to
find a job that's going to pay me weekly
anymore
so youtube has to pay me weekly i have
to be a youtuber because i need
weekly pay i have to have it
fam he was lying now i'm here
obviously i'm on youtube youtuber pay me
don't come weekly
that was all gas weekly pay like saying
they've got your bank details
weekly pay bro i think youtube peg
weekly
uh that's fam uh i was livid
that's lovely jokes i remember i
remember that one time
i think it was my birthday
i think it might have been my birthday
remember what city you were in but was i
know you there was me you maybe
rem or maybe jake oh i know what you're
going to say yeah um
maybe terms does it happen i think it
was a big deal
it was someone's birthday it was a big
deal because everyone was there i don't
think jay was there
no i don't think he was there i can't
remember what c was anyway but um yeah
just for the fans we went somewhere
camera was he probably liveable
um and i remember this was back when i
was on weekly pay
um and i remember going to the cash
machine
saying oh i'm rich i'm rich i'm rich
i've got money what'd you want tonight
guys bowls bottles bottles what is it
what is it what is it
you're talking about i was talking as if
i had tables
i had table money i had tape on my face
i mean i was i wanted to be that guy
um got to the cash machine it just draws
out two bills calm
didn't break a sweat i was like cool
let's let's have fun tonight guys let's
start for everything from me to stuff
once and i went to the
we went to the shrubs shrubs as a club
by the way
uh went in and brought about i swear it
was liverpool because sherlock was
working i
swear it was liverpool it must have been
liverpool because charlotte was like oh
the that i remember the liverpool night
now terrible night
for me terrible night was it that night
i think so
same night i think so you got chucked
out i think so
same night that makes sense i think so
because it was definitely your birthday
it makes sense because yeah you were
flossing
because you were on weekly pay and it
was your birthday you draws out all the
pee
and that i remember that was your
birthday the time you got chatted out as
well so the the
night yeah the nights add up yeah we're
not going to talk about why i got
chucked out
i got back in though you did get i got
back in god knows how
i'm a good talker god knows how fam i've
never known a bouncer to kick someone
out
and let them back in as long as i've
ever been alive same i don't know
i don't know what i said but i got back
in that's a bonkers chat
when i saw you back in there because i
can't even tell it's a certain story but
obviously
i can't just leave it i'm just going to
leave it people are going to be vexing
me but i'm just going to have to leave
it because there's nothing i can say
about exposing
the team but yeah obviously i'd heard
someone had been chucked out for
something
and the person who told me that the
person someone had been chucked out
i remember being like what the [ __ ] yeah
like are you crazy yeah like what do you
mean yeah and i had no idea it was you
yeah
yeah and then i remember like 10 minutes
later you just like coming up to me
i hadn't seen you in half an hour and
you come and say oh they chucked me out
they chucked me out
it was you
[Laughter]
so funny that's jokes so funny that's
[ __ ]
anyway man let's get to a fan request
all right
are you oh you got one to the right yeah
i've got a few i believe
um yeah hi guys i really hope you all
see this um so this year i started
i started talking to this guy and people
knew we were speaking
but i wasn't really close with these
friends corona hit and we weren't in
school anymore and we stopped speaking
but out of nowhere his friends started
hitting me up daily
for chats and stuff for three months we
vibed and i thought something was gonna
happen
we went back to school your man
completely ignored me and the first guy
i was speaking to and came back to speak
with me
and now we speak on we speak at school
and on the phone
but as months passed i started noticing
that his friends would
now try to include me in their
conversations and the second guy
seemed to want to start speaking to me
again when i asked the second guy
why he ignored me he said that it was
because he isn't social
and i don't know whether to be well i
don't know whether to believe him
because i see him always around
different people and stuff
i came to you guys for help because i
started noticing that whenever i spoke
to one guy
the other guy would try and speak to me
also
and i and when i wasn't speaking to the
other one
there's so many others and ones i'm
gonna let you finish
but i haven't the foggiest idea what's
going on
okay it's finished
i'm gonna let you finish my butt what
is going on
jeez man it's confusing me as well
um she's just she just named them
um i came to you guys for help because i
started noticing that whenever i spoke
to one guy the other one
the other would try and speak to me also
and when i wasn't speaking to one
the other also left i don't know if they
haven't seen conversations behind my
back
and if it's a game what should i do
leave it or confront it with love from
south africa okay so basically context
um she was in school corona hit she was
talking to one guy in school before and
then corona here
um she stopped talking to that guy
during the three-month corona period
but she was talking to another bredrin
another guy throughout that three months
period
when they got back to school original
guy guy a was speaking to her again but
guy b
the second guy during corona wasn't
speaking to her so when she confronted
guy b
about why you're speaking to me blah
blah he said oh i'm just not a social
person but she said when she would
notice if guy a wasn't speaking to her
guy b wasn't speaking to her as well
okay okay
okay guy a was speaking to a guy b would
speak with a speech
as well so these two boys that's what
she's asking because she said um
at the end of it she said i don't know
if they're having secret conversations
behind my back is this a game to them
what should i do
that's cool before we get into your
answer have you had a copper test before
a covered test yeah uh no do you know do
you know what they do
do you know what we have to do the nose
thing
yeah i i've cause i've got a test done i
got a test done
probably about a few weeks ago probably
about a month ago
but i hadn't because i hadn't i've never
gotten a testosterone i never asked
because
you had no idea what the what they did
oh yeah bro i had no idea you
have to put the thing on your tonsil as
well and the same thing up your nose
yeah yeah no idea
i gagged i bet you did i [ __ ] go
obviously i've never because they can't
do it for you so i was reading the
instructions everything oh it's just
long it's long long anyway
yeah clover test looks long i'm not
doing it well i will do it i'm happy to
do it but
hopefully i don't have to do it but yeah
um so yeah um
cool so
she's talking to two guys yeah guy a
stopped talking today it's called guy a
jerome
yeah so jerome stopped talking to her
yeah and billy started talking to her
billy oh she started talking to billy
yeah then school's hit again
yeah but at least all of a sudden stop
talking to her yeah but jerome's talking
to her again
yeah out of nowhere yeah so she's now
clean doesn't give a damn about jerome
and has gone up back up to billy and
said why go on why aren't you talking to
me and he's like i'm just not sociable
but then jerome carries on speaking to
her and now billy's speaking to her
again
and then jerome stopped speaking to her
so billy stop speaking to her and she's
thinking
ra okay cool yeah so it's a sim either
it's a two-man thing or it's a no-man
yeah clearly these guys are boys and i'm
not aware of it
cool all right so for me and she's like
is this some kind of game
big man you're talking to two guys
and you're asking is it some kind of
game
[Laughter]
you're trying to do press and you're
like is this some kind
are you man playing me you flipped it
she's gonna listen just like she's gonna
gasp she's gonna realize herself that's
hilarious
um yeah it's a short answer it is a game
and you're you're not playing it right
no it's not going to play right from
both sides
i'm assuming or maybe they're in
different years and stuff like that but
like if you're talking to two guys from
the same school
it's i don't know uh it does seem a bit
fishy if you're unaware that they're
budget i think to be fair i think is a
bit of a coincidence
i don't think i don't see it being a
case of
guys aren't yatty like that as far as i
know guys aren't yet like that like if
me and you coincidentally are talking to
the same girl
i don't care if we're 30 or 13. like
if commissioner didn't mean you were
talking to the same girl like we're not
going to stop talking to her and we're
not going to be like
let's stop talking to her and let's
start talking to her like what is that
yeah that's that's not
especially if i'm a teenager i'm trying
to smash that's
all i'm trying so i'm either interested
or i'm not yeah yeah i don't care what
my boy's doing
i'm trying to smash and if he stops
talking to you i'm gonna i'm going to
start
i need to smash now they're giving me
the
bro so yeah like i don't know i think
she's looking into that
way too far but at the end of the day
yeah if you don't want to feel
uh self-conscious about the situation
don't talk to two guys at the same time
from the same school like what game are
you playing
that's what i want to she's playing any
game you're playing whatever you're
trying to
be part of any sport um clearly this is
it
but no yeah there's there's your answer
love that was a really
confusing but yeah easy result yeah
yeah i don't really know what potential
answer she could have
expected maybe she maybe she really
thought that i genuinely thought that
these guys are like playing games
yeah is this like a guy thing i think
you even that's the thing as well is
like whether they are or they aren't
for starters like that's not something
they're ever going to come clean about
if they are doing it oh yeah for sure
that's so
it's one of those things like if you're
putting yourself in a position that
you're feeling paranoid about this
yeah you should just get out of the
situation in general oh yeah because
whether they are
they are yeah yeah yeah it's all in your
head anyway yeah that makes sense
so if it's giving you mental like
i don't know i said stress if it's
giving you mental stress about the fact
that these two guys might be [ __ ]
around with you because sometimes
they're talking to you sometimes they
aren't
literally just sack them both off quick
things like what even is that
because like if i was if i was ever
chatting to two things
that i knew had interaction whether
whether i thought they were friends or
not yeah yeah yeah
they had interaction with each other
even if for one moment
i got suspicious of the fact that they
might be knowing or they might be
talking about me
i promise you know i'm looking at the
same day i promise you now i'm like i'm
i ain't going
too much anxiety every time i walk down
the corridor
every time i'm in the canteen i'm
[ __ ] sweating
oh i know what you mean bro ah yeah man
yeah man
yeah man that's tough um yeah you so
you've got yours you need to just get
out of the situation basically
um yeah talking to two guys from the
same spot isn't isn't ideal
especially especially when you you've
got no choice but to see them five days
a week yeah
like it's not that's dead it's not like
that it's not healthy at all it doesn't
make sense ah yeah oh yeah i feel like
that's that was easy open and shut
bro hit me
did you as this is a random one did you
ever
have to or have you ever been in a
situation where you were younger
where you've had to or if you've ever
been asked by a girl if you're a virgin
so when you were a virgin has any girl
ever asked you if you were a virgin
a girl that you were actively trying to
smash
um
probably yes yes um because i lost my
virginity in
college or sixth or whatever um
and everyone knows the story the
play-doh about your story where
i asked my girlfriend out at the time in
year nine and ran away or no yeah ten
sorry and ran away
um i was obviously a virgin then and i
remember
i think i remember asking one of my boys
for advice on how to pat into smash
and that's hilarious that's actually
hilarious but the thing is i don't
remember the actual context of the
conversation
no because i i knew he wasn't a virgin
because you told me and
i just knew um and i was like what do i
do
do you know what i mean how do i
maneuver
yeah to get bring this girl to the yard
and
plan out a bang session bro how do you
plan that bro
i'm sixteen fam i don't know
oh yeah 10 15 yeah yeah i remember when
i was like
14 year 9 one guy called tom rolled into
art class one day
talking the most about how he smashed
his girlfriend over the weekend
and i was thinking swear what a lucky
guy fam i think you can swear
and he was trying to chuck it to me i
remember this is one of the most
um self-aware moments of my life
in which i for some reason realized at
that point like big man you're too young
to be having sex i don't know why that
came to my head because i was horny as
hell
but it gets my head like why are you
doing that yeah um because his girl was
the same age and i was just like
damn i think because his girl was like
really like she was he quite young
looking
okay that might have been the team she
had like batty and t and stuff
not really she she'd hit buby for sure
um
so yeah she did have like some tea or
whatever but like she just
looks so funny she looks young i
remember looking at she was like i think
it's because she was petite
she was petite okay okay okay then once
yeah yeah yeah
so like like i remember thinking when he
told me that they smashed and stuff i
remember
picturing her and i was thinking that's
not that seems weird bro
like even it's painful yeah i i i it's
like i put myself in the body of a 25
year old man
and thought back about 14 year old
people smashing do you know what i mean
how about think about now if a 14 year
old person told me now that they thought
they go
i'll be like jesus bro calm down yeah
relax you're way too young
yeah what's that that's how i felt when
i was 14. yeah yeah yeah even though
all i wanted to do was smash yeah but i
wanted to smash girls with body yeah do
you know what i mean yeah i want to
watch
women when i was 14.
who knows what i want to smash women
yeah um but
he come into art class talking the most
one time talk about ah me and my
girlfriend the other day her parents
were out and we fought and all this
stuff
and all i could think of was like how
did you
pack how did you pattern like what in
what situation were you
in to pat on a beat i don't even think
i'd kiss someone at this point
at this point that he's talking it was
like late year eight or early year nine
i don't think i'd lip someone yeah and i
was thinking did you just talk like
shall we just
bang yeah all like um like
were you getting that nitty-gritty with
the lipstick that age
it was the next it was the next step it
was the next step i was thinking bro
i was pulling my hair out thinking how
did you do it
i can't even how did you do it i can't
fathom
i honestly can't find them because you
remember what your boy even said to you
no
of course i don't of course i don't of
course i don't
the funny thing is i obviously because i
lost my virginity in college i didn't
smash her until
[Music]
probably
i think i'd come back from college on
like a holiday or whatever and then
i think i was smashing like year 13. i
was sorry i dated her in year
my day and every year 10 year 10 no just
in year 10 or yeah
till like the first like semester or
whatever yeah 11 something like that
but yeah i didn't smash it for time slow
down yeah it was mud
when i um what was it when i was dating
a girl
before i lost my virginity i remember
she texted me to
ask i remember one day i was chilling
one of my boys
and um she
asked me oh are you a virgin
and i remember looking at my phone i
remember the whole scenario
it's so weird i can remember exactly
where i was i was sitting on like a pole
um i was at a field like a football
field
with my boys and we were playing
football after school and i'm sitting on
a pole
and i look i must have been year 12
maybe
i looked down on my phone saw the text
and i mean
i would have started if it was
face-to-face i wouldn't know what to say
but i remember when i looked down on my
phone and my boy sitting next to me and
i looked down my phone and said like are
you a virgin
my heart sank because i knew she wasn't
okay
i knew she wasn't this was the same yeah
who's
whose car i saw outside her yeah yeah
yeah man's yard didn't they yeah yeah
this was like way before that point
um so she's like oh were you
she's just asking me in conversation
like oh there was no sexy channel you
know there was no sense of chat
or maybe it was a little bit flirtatious
because we were kind of
like talking and stuff we weren't like i
haven't done anything yet she asked me
you're a virgin
fam the way i
the impasse i was at in my mind where i
was like i need to lie
but i can't lie because
at this age that i'm at there's no way i
just randomly smash someone do you know
what i mean
and i'm like i need to figure out how to
navigate this
through this conversation without her
thinking that i'm a [ __ ] because i'm so
the virgin
and i think the text i replied was like
yeah like
virgin like it's such a weird word like
he's such a labyrinth of a phrase
virgin like you know i've uh
you know i've like i've i've done a
couple stinks
and like i think my exact words were
like
i i've done everything but stick it in
yeah that's what my textbook was like oh
i've done everything
but stick like literally stick my tool
inside the vagina yeah i've done
everything else yeah i just hadn't
done nothing i know i've done mouth to
mouth and that's that's
done cpr and that's it bro so i've done
everything except stick it in and i
can't like
i remember her like um reply back was
like
oh dot dot dot so you are a virgin then
fam i went my heart was crumb because i
think
she's gonna she's gonna lock me up she
just set me up and i remember being like
and literally same thing i remember
going straight up to the
virgin like what is this why are we
throwing around this bird it's such a
toxic word
like with me i'm more intellect like i
like to [ __ ] your mind you know i mean
i like to [ __ ] the mind like virgin i i
don't like that word
it doesn't sit well with me i was using
any excuse for
any excuse i was so embarrassed to be a
virgin i was so embarrassed
to be i was definitely one of the last
ones in my form
to lose my virginity um because no when
i was in year 10
in my form class obviously the year that
i asked out the play by
um the chick and ran away um most of the
boys that i [ __ ] um hanged around with
in my form class weren't virgins and i
was one of the last ones to lose my
virginity but i didn't lose my virginity
until like the year and a half later
anyway
i remember when um i remember the period
of time i was with
said person in year 10 a lot of people
were asking
around that time are have you kissed
yeah or have you [ __ ] yet or are you
do you know what i mean especially the
mandem
yeah yeah i don't know if the girls are
asking her but obviously the mandem were
asking me
and it was one of them ones where it's
like just like nah like
one obviously in year in year ten
the same way you said um that that 14
year old brother was like oh yeah smash
my goal over the weekend
like where are you smashing i'm not
bringing home my girlfriend in year 10
to my yard cause
i'm not i'm just not it doesn't work
i've got no other
where am i going to stop because i'm not
my i'm not losing my virginity in a park
you need to be comfortable yeah we need
some form of romance yeah bro
you mean yeah yeah yeah so i don't know
i
i don't know how dead man did it but i
don't know how i don't know how
demanding i don't know how that i
remember one
i remember my
one of my boys he had such a good
relationship with his mom
okay like him his brother and their mom
were just like a trio like they were
boys they spoke about anything
and i remember being so jealous that
like he basically
he basically came forward to his mum
and just basically said to his mom what
he would say to me
in that like i'm trying to lose my
virginity
today like i need it done i need this
out my head
and i need not like not like he needs
his mom to help him
like uh he could get pumped but like he
needs his mom to be able to allow him
don't cockblock me it's just
facilitating facilitate the team
because i need to knock this one out
yeah yeah
so fam she facilitated the thing fam he
found a thing i remember he was talking
to a team that was a year younger
so he must have been fifth i want to say
he was 15
maybe 16. ting he was yeah
16 ting was 15 i remember she
it was it was you know i remember she
was piff i remember she was
she didn't go to our school she just
lived in the area that he lived in yeah
yeah yeah she clocked her one time
yeah after a little while of talking
sus that uh she was like
keen not keen but like either she wasn't
a virgin or like he just knew he could
pattern this
so after just like a week of talking he
was like bang
this is the yeah i'm gonna do my
virginity like he
tag he was at that point where he was
targeting yeah
just so he could lose his virginity i
wasn't there yet
damn i was not there fam and he randomly
banged told me one time he was like cool
um she's coming over tonight i've told
my mom she's coming over
my mom's going to head out for the
evening i'm going to bring her back i'm
going to smash and he actually did as
well
from fair play yes she did and he he
knocked it want that one out and was
just like
breathing again i can get back to
football he just needed that one out of
his head yeah
it was mad fair play oh that was not how
it went down for me boy
i'm trying to remember what mine was how
about have you spoke about it
you said about your dorms right yeah she
came down and sucked you off zion that's
mad to me
that's mad to me i remember the girl who
i did end up losing my virginity to
the first so i took her out on a date
went to cinema to uh
god knows what we watched we went to
cinema and um
we went back to mine after my mom was
out went back to mine after just to
chill
off the bat as soon as we got in my room
she's lips in me and whipped my tool out
and she's bashing me off and i was
thinking
i'm gonna smash now i'm about to smash
now
yeah i was so gassed because thinking
she's wasting no time yeah yeah oh
yeah this is our first lips and she's
wrenching my tool out oh wow like this
is it
oh i'll be petrified i would be pet i
was scared i was
horny i was horny pointing this out the
fear i was too horny to care about
being scared yeah yeah yeah and she
rushed into it so quickly it kind of
got me past the fair bit yeah because
she's gagging through she said like
oh like if if she said something like
oh like just like [ __ ] me or something
like that that would have scared me okay
but because she just got straight into
the action i was not scared
i was thinking we're banging now yeah
that's certified we're banging now
and i'm guessed for it um fam but
turns out that's all she wanted to do
was just lips and bash me off
and we did not smash for ages
months fam all it was was bashing and
stinks
four months months until we smashed
i was livid about it i lived i thought
was gonna be on day one i was deceived
were you seeing her was it just a thing
seeing i've seen well yes
took my time i've seen her like
consistently how about telling me
she was my girlfriend she'd met my mom
everything
oh wow it was long but obviously i
didn't do that just so i could yeah i
don't know i know i know
her boyfriend but like um yeah i my high
my hopes were so high
my hopes were so high thinking this is
hate hand jobs
i know you do you know what's weird i
think you hate hand jobs so much because
you're circumcised
uh i don't know i don't know
we'll never know and there's someone
who's literally unless you meet someone
who's had a circumcision as an
adult and says cool this is what it's
like pre-circumcision and this was like
post circumcision
um like i don't know it would because i
remember there was a
there was a guy who used to hang around
kind of like a friend of a friend
he used to like he was in the group of
friends that kind of
we hung out with one of that group of
friends so we kind of knew him via that
if that makes sense
yeah so um
his nickname was snippy because he was
circumcised
[Laughter]
how is man getting a nickname for doing
for having a circumcised piece nothing
he had control over
it's not like man got a bad trick tony's
name was snippy kind of
nippy i forgot sometimes yeah
when i tell the story there's something
about this environment yeah that sets my
mind off into different
lengths yeah i know what you mean
because i haven't thought about this guy
since i was a kid his nickname was
snippy and i remember
asking like why why is your nickname
snippy yeah he was
asked cause i'm circumcised in it and i
was like i'll swear okay
and i remember first of all i remember
one of the third because i think this is
when i just got into
bashing i just got into wanking though
and i remember thinking
oh how do you wank yeah that must hurt
that must hurt because i'm not drawing
for cream every time
that's long and i remember i
specifically remember thinking
unless you're using cream that's
friction
and then i remember obviously i don't
talk to guys like that
just finding out that if they're snipped
or not and i specifically
remember you telling me a decade later
like just like you just said like oh i
hate hand jobs yeah and i'm thinking how
can you hate hand jobs
i'm grateful for any yet to touch my
tall phone what do you mean you hate
them
i'm grateful yeah um and i remember
thinking
and then obviously i knew you were
muslim so i was like oh he's rag go
circumcised
maybe that's why maybe that's why he
hates it because it just hurts
i mean
yes and no like i hate hand jobs
as a stand-alone foreplay act
yes if i'm getting ahead whilst
i'm getting stroked those are two
completely different yeah
sensations those are two completely
different sensations
if i was in your shoes when you said
you've come home from a little thing
with your girl
she's lips in man off and just knocking
me out
she has to leave the yard she has to
leave the yard
now i was here for it she could have
just took obviously back then i don't
know i probably would have been there
for it
you know what i know now oh yeah now
that wouldn't bang another one bang
not even now obviously because no yeah i
could just come to my yard lips me
tugging me off and leave
no no getting your knees will go in your
back
get on your knees or get in your back
this is i don't know what this is
but it doesn't end here i'm telling you
that now
[Laughter]
get on your knees or get on your [ __ ]
back oh
god i don't know what you're starting
from but this is
not this is not how you end all right
this is not how it ends
so maybe like probably how old am i 29
so let's say if i was 20 years old
and somebody had to try to bash me off
obviously i had sex then so
i'll be like no you have to do something
about this so i don't know man i don't
know it's just a weird also
because obviously the sensitive part is
the helmet
so if she's just bashing off my actual
shaft
it doesn't do it literally does nothing
for me literally does nothing for me
obviously yes i can fill your hand on it
blah blah blah it doesn't do it there's
no nerves or anything there's just
nothing
but obviously if it's a simultaneous
sloppy top with the
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
different so
girls that are listening and be like oh
how can you not like hand jobs um just a
standalone hand job is
is trash fair play g it's absolute trash
but fair play i love the dual action
who doesn't who doesn't that's that's
wonderful
it is fair play g um should we do
the [ __ ] let's i've got a lot
let me settle into this one i got one
right where is she cool am i the [ __ ]
my boyfriend made me insecure about some
girls on insta
in parentheses slash brackets she says
i'm never normally insecure i don't care
about likes and [ __ ] gang i love that
um we had problems with a specific girl
because of the past
this led to him showing me chats
this i'm gonna say that
[Laughter]
this led to him showing me chats with
girls and him baiting himself out
as there were nudes and inappropriate
messages on there am i the answer for
telling him to
wait am i the [ __ ] for telling him i
forgive him
but still being off with him a month
later because i want to be over it but
i'm not
but i'm not and i'm thinking is it me
that's the issue with being so
chilled and relaxed with him in the
first place he looks at me as one of the
lads
as do his friends and i and my psycho
girl mates
tell me that's why um he thinks he can
get away with [ __ ] because he does stuff
behind my back
and but i've never on this but he's
never understood that he's
her girls are like nutty or whatever
i've been in three serious relationships
and this has this has happened every
time he's never been in one i'm the
first serious relationship
from both your point of views as people
i relate to you please help me out your
podcast is sick by the way
gang so summary
she's got a gal she's got a man um
who's made her insecure um he's [ __ ]
up um
so hence the reason why she he's showing
her his phone
she's seen a couple nudes here and there
she's forgiven him but she's still mad
at him so she brought up months later
her girlfriends are saying that you've
kind of aided
and embedded this because you were so
children so laxed in the first place
whereas he has no clue what's going on
is she the [ __ ] for bringing it up
again a month later after saying she
forgives him
cool so for me
firstly let's get into this
he viewed the she viewed the chats
listen like as far as i'm aware
no and this i'm not just blaming her for
this
i'm especially blaming him but like
if i if i offer in the in the heat of an
argument if we're beefing about like you
said
issues with a previous girl or stuff
like that i'm assuming it got to the
point
where either she said show me the chat
and prove it or he said i'll show you
the chat and prove it
big man even if i say to you i'll show
you the chat and prove it
for the sake of our relationship please
say no because
it's never ever going to solve anything
he's a dumb ass for keeping it on his
phone he kept
nudes on his phone and let his girl see
his phone what kind of rookie
what kind of chat is that yeah what is
that what is that
but yeah never ever ever ever ever
ever under any circumstances i don't
care if they give you the phone
with the with the passcode do not look
yeah for the sake of your own
relationship unless you want to break up
there and then there and then yeah yeah
do not look look yeah because it doesn't
matter what you see it doesn't matter if
it seems legit because
if if you open a conversation and it's
with a girl especially now that on
whatsapp you can just delete what you
want to delete yeah
like if he says oh here's a conversation
with this girl have a look
if you look on there and it's either
option a which is what's happened to her
there's nudes galore on there there's
filthy chat on there and he's just
hotting himself up
that's option a which is obviously bad
option b
is it seems like a perfectly polite nice
conversation
and you will automatically think there's
something else to it
either he's deleted messages or
this is some kind of hidden code yeah
because she knows he's got a girl
something's your paranoia is not going
to let it go because you already said
they were paranoid about this girl in
the first place
um or there's an issue with this girl in
the first place so just don't look at
the phone ever
and dudes bro if you're talking smack to
another girl receiving who's just for
god's sake delete your conversations
delete your conversations if you're
having them like i'm not condoning them
but if you're i can't stop you doing
what you're doing and if you're going to
do it and you want to stay in this
relationship that you're in just delete
it's laziness now yeah now you're being
lazy and this is the the laziness
and disrespectful this is what we've
said before yeah
i don't condone g in but
if you're gonna do it you best do it
right if you're going to do it and you
love your girl and you want to stay in
this relationship
like cuff your tracks yeah she should
never even be suspicious of fish
in the first place in the first place so
if you're out here and you've still got
nudes on your phone
then this isn't relationship you want to
be in yeah for sure because you don't
even have enough respect for your goal
to delete your messages
so i don't even think it's a case of i
know she said like ah
her girls are saying oh he treats you
like one of the lads and his friends
treat you like one of the lads
first of all his if you're in any kind
of
good relationship your
boyfriend's friends treating you like
one of the lads is a good thing
oh rags i would never treat any of my
friends girlfriends any other way
that's a good thing as far as i'm
concerned but
um and your boyfriend treating you like
one of the lads isn't a bad thing either
but don't listen to your girls and say
oh that's why he thinks he can do what
he wants that has nothing to do with it
he thinks he can do it once because he
just doesn't care he because he does
what he wants he does what he wants yeah
he thinks he can do it once because he
does he because he does it and he
doesn't he clearly doesn't care about
the consequences
um so what i'm saying is yeah rags like
in question in my opinion in the
question of
are you the [ __ ] yes
you are because you've somewhat you've
said you've forgiven him
and it's a month later and you clearly
haven't
saying you forgive someone and actually
forgiving someone are too completely
different of course
so if you haven't forgiven him you need
to be honest with yourself i'm honest
with you because i haven't forgiven you
brother
and you guys need to take whatever steps
you need to take from here
to either break up or find a way that
you can forgive him or whatever
if you still want to be there but my
personal opinion in
in the actual matter as it is your girls
could share they don't know what they're
about
um that's a fact your girls are sharp
they don't know what to write about
that doesn't none of what they said
makes sense um but
what will say is your man doesn't
respect you that's a fact he doesn't
respect you and yes i agree as well you
are the answer for
saying you forgive him but not forgiving
him a month later like your actions
proven that you don't forgive him um
which isn't yes it's an [ __ ] thing
because you just asked that by the
[ __ ]
but it's also not the most unexpected
results
do you know what i mean like if if that
happened in my relationship if i was
seeing someone in my relationship and
i've got news on my phone and
um i got questions about it and i lied
or something or trying to hide it or
whatever
and she told me she forgive me but it's
done bro
that's the thing as well like i expect
the relationship to be done from now as
soon as i've shown you the phone yeah
and it's still got nudes
from the girl that we have issues about
the thing is done
it must be because i am now not
necessarily on edge but like it's more
of a case of
i don't know it's weird it's i would
just be are we moving weird around her
do you know what i mean it would just be
weird
it's hard to explain but i just know the
feeling at the certain unless he's
sorry unless he's just acting so blase
he just doesn't care that
yeah he's a girl seeing the nudes yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah cracking
it's just like where do we go from here
yeah exactly that
you've just closed exactly you've got a
feeling yeah you have
you have paranoia about this girl that i
that i have to
that i have history with or whatever
your paranoia is
solidified by you looking in my whatsapp
and seeing
nudes or said girl i've said girl even
if it isn't from said girl because i
don't know if she specified if it was
that girl
but anyway even if it was or if it
wasn't you're paranoid about
me talking to another girl you've gone
on my phone you've seen naked
[ __ ] on my phone naked [ __ ] and
and sexy chat
where do we go from here it's done out
and that's the thing is that you are the
[ __ ] for saying oh i forgive you and
then a month later
you clearly haven't but just you're not
the [ __ ] for not forgiving him
because
where do we go from here i'm a liar i'm
a liar and a cheat yeah
i don't expect you to forgive me yeah
i'm a liar and a cheat
i've also feel like it boils down to
for women anyway not necessarily for
women it could be for anyone like
because if the roles were reversed and
she got clocked with a phone with a
naked guy or whatever like a dick pic
whoever
i feel like it's a case of the reason
why she might be asking this is because
she doesn't want to leave him of course
she doesn't want to leave him
of course she doesn't want to know i
feel like she's looking for reasons
to not necessarily to stay but to
justify why she should stay
yeah of course because it's uh
it's sticky because at the end of the
day you said you've been in three
serious relationships this is his first
one
so in my assumption this is just my
assumption that was such an irrelevant
statement as well by the way
but go on what she said oh the three and
the one
yeah like it sounds like she yeah it
sounds like she's justifying
his actions by the fact that he's never
been in a serious relationship oh he
just needs to learn how to act
in seriously he's a grown man he's a
girl
you don't need practice at this
you don't need to learn these things you
know them you know right from wrong
it doesn't matter if it's his first
serious relationship
but maybe my not my maybe my assumption
is like
she's maybe they're in deep obviously
her third relationship definitely in
deep his first
they probably live together i'm just
running out there you're throwing out
there they probably live together
or like he's around hers or she's around
here's a lot of the time yeah it's one
of them ones where
i feel like maybe they've got similar
circles as well
so it's going to be harder to break up
so there's a thing she's looking for
reasons to stay
all categorical reasons to leave yeah
and
what she thinks are categorical reasons
to leave clearly aren't
and um i don't know man she needs to
leave him
but she just has as harsh as it sounds i
think you do because where do we go from
here where
that's it where's he in game where is
where you're not gonna like you're not
you haven't forgiven this guy it's not a
it's not a small thing for you clearly
and it's like i don't know bro like it
just changes
there's certain actions people take that
just change your perception of them
yeah like oh yeah 100 100 like i love
you with ev
all of my being but if you
like stole something from my mom's yard
i can forgive you but i'm never going to
see you the same you will never we're
never going to go back to normal
something you can never forget yeah
exactly we're never ever going to go
back to normal and i'll still be your
friend forever
but i just there's something i see you
different now
and i can't understand it wait because
when you said that i laughed i was
thinking i'm
never gonna do that by the way just
throw it out there i know i don't know
how that came to my head but like
it's just something just about all right
cool well i just see you as a different
person
yeah i think i think the best thing for
you to do because this is obviously
still on your mind
so you actually need to sit your boy
down and be like literally ask him where
do we go from here
because this is obviously still on your
mind i feel like you need to be honest
with him and not not
go up to him and be like i want to end
this blah blah just literally ask him
where do we go from here because this is
on my mind speak your feelings and let
him speak his feelings and then
just go from there because that's your
thing you know what they need to do is
your thing what's my thing
just be two people who aren't in a
relationship together okay
yeah so um you need to separate
emotion from logic i would say let's say
let's use the word logic
so if you have a com if you're having a
conversation with your partner you need
to remove all emotion and just think
logically
and just have a conversation logically
like if you're looking imagine yourself
giving your friends advice that's the
kind of conversation you need to have
with your boyfriend and that's the best
way to actually
think and act in those kind of
situations and so anyway you can
understand each other's perspectives
because you're not wasting time trying
to defend yourself exactly because when
you're in an argument with someone
you hear what they say but you're not
really taking it in because your all
your brain is doing is how can i defend
myself
it's just ping pong yeah like you ain't
got time to be respecting next man's
moves yeah because you're just like i
need to stay alive
i need to retaliate yeah but if yeah if
you if you disassociate yourselves and
just see it from a perspective all right
cool you're just a guy
and i'm just a girl like in this
scenario if it were two other people
like just ask him like bro like big man
ting i won't be offended and stuff like
that like
i've removed all emotions there's no
consequences here like
i know you think you want to be in this
relationship with me but your actions
are saying
otherwise like do you actually want to
be in this relationship with me because
now's the time to tell me
and i won't take it to heart if you just
say hey bro i'm in my 20s or maybe the
30s or whatever i'm in my 20s
and i just want i'm i feel like i'm in a
position where i just want to [ __ ]
and i'm i know we're in a serious
relationship but there's another part of
me that just thinks
i'm young i'm attracted to other women
and i want to experiment
i want to experience other women yeah
like those are the only situations that
you'll ever find out and you actually
might be able to see his side clearly
without taking it personally and be like
yeah cool this isn't about me yeah
this is it's never about you yeah it's
actually not going to be about you
because he's with you yeah if
you were a piece of [ __ ] he wouldn't be
with you anyway but it's just like maybe
just sit down
hey man like what do you want like do
you want to
bang other girls and this isn't this
isn't your girlfriend asking you this
this is like your friend now like i'm
one of the lads
do you want to be out here slinging dick
for a year do you want us do you want us
to take a year apart
so you can do your thing is that what
you actually want and you actually might
find out
some home troops and allowing him to be
in that position
might actually allow him to have another
thought and think
you know what i know i'm acting like i
do but now that i think about it
i actually don't yeah it's the ego thing
for me yeah i don't want to sleep with
anyone else
it's an ego thing for me i've got an
inferiority complex
and it just does something nice on my
ego when i
i know a girl that's attracted to me
it's nice to see some guys
like to know that someone who isn't
their girlfriend is actually attractive
of course
because guys know that their girlfriend
kind of has to be attracted to them
it's kind of their job so sometimes it's
just nice
to know that someone else finds you
attractive as well and maybe that's his
thing
yeah maybe he's like oh hey i don't know
man maybe when i get a nude
from this girl i'm just like ra it makes
me feel good about myself and i have no
intentions of doing anything yeah
you might not have [ __ ] it might not
even see you know like he might have no
intention of doing any of these things
but unless you have this open plan
conversation
you will never ever find out yeah and at
the end of it that actually might be the
only way you could ever forgive him
that's yeah you will probably still
won't forget but you you
will probably forgive him after that so
you need to separate logic from emotion
um and have one of those sit down
conversations and whatever and just go
from there because that's that is
probably the best advice
gang that was a good one bro you did
well there man
that was good i like that in mind
yourself right let's wrap it around
that's why
all right see you guys soon